you
hello hello ambassador resume zoo yet
speaking ah hello my name is Adam Smith
calling from Nobel Prize org the
official website of the Nobel Prize in
Stockholm yeah and we'd like to record
very brief interviews with new laureates
may we speak for just two or three
minutes all right thank you he will you
add questions or you want because I lost
I'll ask questions if I may our actual
but may I start by offering our
congratulations on their water than oh
thank you very much thank you now in
their announcement the Nobel Committee
states that through this award they're
seeking to contribute to the elimination
of chemical weapons how do you think
this Nobel Prize will help with your
mission um fact that the organization
has achieved a quite you know
substantially over the past 16 years by
verifying the elimination of eighty
percent of existing stockpiles of
chemical weapons possessed by several
states parties clearly twenty percent of
those stockpiles remain to be destroyed
in the coming years but also
illustration is Syria poses a particular
challenge to our organization where
there is a considerable amount of
chemical weapons I think the Nobel Peace
Prize in fact will it will give a new
impetus and encouragement and I should
say a great incentive to our staff who
are working in the Secretariat and who
are deployed also in Syria for the past
2-3 weeks and that this will boost their
morale in order to fulfill their de
mission thank you and what message do
you think this award is meant to convey
to the world I see it as a recognition
in fact of contributions made by our
organization to global peace and
security over the past 16 years of its
existence clearly this award in fact
there is a cognition of though all those
who worked in the OPCW as well as all
those who represented their countries
here in the hague attested to the
organization over those years i think
the credit should go to all of them as
well as the face parties in fact who
were determined to fulfill the
objectives of the chemical weapons
convention so I i see that is a great
acknowledgement of all this success
story over than 16 years now the
announcement will focus yet more
attention on the problem of chemical
weapons how can people around the world
who concern who are concerned by this
problem help with the opcw's work III
think clearly we have to raise awareness
about the risks security risk associated
with the handling of you know do you use
chemical materials throughout the world
and we have done a great deal to this
effect but much remains to be done we
have to raise awareness among scientific
communities academia and all those who
are others who are dealing with the
chemistry because there are serious
risks associated with that and to my
pleasure we have reached a level of 190
stays bodies actually in a few days
Syria will become a party so with Syria
it's going to be 196 other countries
remain outside of the organization we
want to get you know them on board and
that them joining the organization as
early as possible but along with that we
we need them in fact I've more wider i
should say awareness-raising among all
relevant communities on the security
risks involved in in the chemistry does
indeed and then the announcement
mentions not just syria but other states
that still have stockpiles of chemical
weapons most notably USA and Russia so
there's still much to do in fact that
the United States has reached level of
ninety percent of destruction of own
stockpiles and in the Russian Federation
they reached same with six percent of
the destruction after
of destruction so these are indeed quite
significant achievements the destruction
of chemical weapons is a very costly
labor-intensive and in fact and
dangerous operation we have to recognize
their achievements but also their I have
to recognize their commitment in this
endeavors and we expect them in fact to
fulfill their obligations in the in the
coming years thank you very much indeed
now this announcement comes on what was
already a busy day for you because the
Executive Council is in session this
week isn't it yes EDD castle has been
session Tuesday and and this was last
day in fact the castle has just adopted
its report but the news of the nobel
peace prize in fact they were really
overwhelming and at this morning session
when I lost it and they they welcomed
that of course and they were very moved
that's very good to you very nice to
hear well thank you very much indeed for
speaking to us and it's been a pleasure
to speak to any congratulations again on
the award Thank You Man thank you